214 is the final. So
that's what we have from here.
Let's check in with the guys on
site Jack and Rodney are joined
by a very special. Hello
gentlemen, happy holidays. Wow.
Okay.
Real, real, real receiver,
certified Superstar for being
honest.
Didi. Laughs. You don't see this
kind of just blow out
often in the NFL. How good does
this one feel? I owe. This is
huge man, I think We had one
early on in the season and we
kind of had a talk like this.
It's a great feeling, you don't
happen
too many times in the NFL and I
just found out that we scored
probably the highest this
season. So it's huge. You know,
Martin Cooper's frustration this
weekend, him speaking out
that that really affect the
offense because it seemed like
you guys came out here with a
bunch of Firepower.
Not at all man. We understand
what we got going in his room
and
we got guys that can eat on
outside. And obviously we got
guys that we can hand the ball
off to. So the list could go on
and on it's just the offense
that we had to get going
eventually and And I was a great
night to get you started,
everybody saying the same thing,
what's wrong with
the Dallas offense. What's wrong
with this? What's wrong with
that, right? Asked me last
night. Like, I don't think
anything's wrong with the Dallas
offense. What are you
guys thinking? What are some of
the internal conversations with
all this outside noise going on?
I mean, we understand
like everything that was going
wrong for the for us and
just able to week in and week
out, connected.
Obviously. He's missing a couple
throws drop balls. It
was a lot of things with
different individuals and
just coming out here and playing
our best. Just putting
a put it all on. Tape and
gonna be a great time tomorrow.
One of the things that really
impressed me about you.
Everybody talks about your play,
making ability, but no
one really talks about your
toughness going across
the middle with no hesitation.
You're catching balls. They're
hitting you low
to me. Talk to me about your
toughness going, across
the meadow man. It's tough to be
in that slot. I tell you that
its
pros and cons for show, and
today was one of those days
while I was feeling it. No
matter what. And I you could
tell us come to a game plan
going across the middle is going
to be tough. It's a lot
of bodies going on and just
Got a navigated Man Without
solid.
And Dak Prescott has been
through a whole lot over your
time in Dallas. How is pairing
with Prescott impacted your
career. It was fairly easy, man.
Just just a the, the time
he's had before me and
obviously, the experience he
had week in and week out.
So just kind of picking this
bring my rookie year, made it
so easy. He kind of simple the
game down a lot for me
mentally. So physically, I could
just go out there and
play fast and
you know, just make plays the
boy dings man 11 interceptions.
He gets another Other one
tonight. You go against them
every day, in practice. I mean,
what is it about this dude?
That keeps the ball keeps
falling right in his hand, man.
He is a receiver.
I don't understand what why
people keep trying them on go
balls,
deep balls. Cuz like at that
point
you just playing with fire. And
as you can see this, the first
defensive play and I saw
the ball go up. And at that
point, he didn't even look at
the deep
as a receiver. Yeah. He is the
receiver. So just going, I'm
going against him week in and
week out
day in and day out. Should I say
all the way from training camp?
Us, it just go together and then
we came in together. So,
we understand the pressure that
we have upon us a year to, but
he's going in and ready to work.
But then whatever,
what's it like for you going up
against digs on a daily basis?
It kills them
is a great matchup. It's a great
natural.